so you're China you're constantly on the
verge of war with the West you don't
have many friends and right now you're
in the middle of a really really bad
couple of years covid lockdowns Bank
runs a real estate crisis an energy
crisis America all of that is weighing
down your economy but there's also one
other problem you're facing that not
many people think about oil see just
like America's love affair with the
black gold you need oil to keep the
lights on in your Empire in fact you
desperately need oil more than America
ever has you're not just bigger than
America you also consume more energy
than any other country on the planet you
consume more oil than any other country
on the planet second only to America
oil Powers everything your military your
factories all the construction you've
been building it fuels your peasant's
daily lives if your oil supply got cut
off for whatever reason it could mean
literal collapse
just look at how much Europe is
panicking right now because Putin shut
off their oil and the same goes for
America that's why America has already
got to Great Lengths to secure their oil
at this hour American and Coalition
forces in support of an international
effort to disarm Iraq to free its people
I want the American people to know that
the use of force
is not our first choice
it's not a choice that I make lightly
the Gulf War the 2002 Venezuelan coup
the execution of Muammar Gaddafi all of
that was related to America's
unquenchable thirst for oil and as China
you're 100 down to do the exact same
thing but there's just one problem in
America's case they can just invade or
overthrow any country they want to to
secure the resources they need while
bananas stage Aku and Guatemala want
Copper overthrow a democratically
elected president in Chile want oil
invade Iraq there's no question that the
presence of petroleum has sparked great
power involvement that's because America
can get away with it they run NATO they
have the strongest military they have
the most influence they have the most
votes in the U.N they control the
narrative of what's right and what's
wrong that's why when they invade a
country they don't have to worry about
annoying things like sanctions or Global
outcry but you're not America you are
China you do not have that luxury for
one you don't have the money invading
Iraq costs America over two trillion
dollars and invading Afghanistan and
Casa America another 2 trillion dollars
and number two you do not control the
narrative you invade one insignificant
country and boom suddenly the whole
world will be up in arms about it so
instead you have to go about your
invasions a little bit more creatively
you want to save money and avoid
International backlash while still
getting the resources you desperately
need to keep things in your dystopia
running smoothly and the best way to do
this is through debts and right now one
of the countries are looking to enslave
in debt is Iraq and yes just like
America this is all about oil except
America had to resort to Violent Warfare
for you you'll just have to stick with
financial Warfare
stay dangerous and this is China's
thirst for oil
[Music]
right now China has been in the middle
of one of the worst droughts and heat
waves in history the Heat and lack of
rain is destroying food crops affecting
animals and making life in the hottest
provinces harder than ever but that's
not all because the drought has also
dried up 66 Rivers across China which is
a problem with some Chinese provinces
get up to 80 of their electricity from
hydropower add this to the fact that
people are using air conditioners more
than ever because of the Heat Wave and
you're faced with a pretty serious
problem there is not enough electricity
to meet demand things have gone so bad
that you've even started rationing
electricity the iconic Shanghai Skyline
had to be plunged Into Darkness offices
were using giant blocks of ice to cool
down buildings where air conditioning
units had to be turned off and in the
Sichuan Province factories in 19 cities
had to stop their operations to save
electricity long story short combined
four years of really bad luck with a
series of unfortunate yet mostly
preventable events and you had a really
bad energy Crunch and the people were
pissed and rightfully so this is were
already suffering from the coveted
lockdowns and now factories had to be
shut up because there wasn't enough
electricity after that the growing
tension between China and America and
you China are backed into a position
where you're gonna have to find a
reliable source of energy fast because
if America ever decides to go on the
offensive a heat wave and a little
energy rationing are going to be the
least of your worries
in China authorities are battling one of
the worst droughts seen in more than 50
years
they have never seen severe power
rationing and draw like this the
devastation China has warned that his
fall Harvest is under threat leaving
thousands of Chinese citizens in need of
government support even before the
drought China wasn't exactly energy
independent you're responsible for 13 of
the world's oil consumption second only
to America and almost all of that oil is
imported right now you get most of your
oil from the same place everyone else
does Saudi Arabia oil from Saudi Arabia
accounts for 17 of China's imported
Supply with Russia not far behind at 15
but here's the problem with those two
sources Saudi Arabia is loyal to America
at least for the time being China is
working hard to break that loyalty so
make sure you subscribe to learn how in
a future video on this but because Saudi
Arabia is loyal to America currently if
America decides to slap you with
sanctions or go to war almost a fifth of
your imported oil supply would probably
disappear Into Thin Air that's already
enough to cause a crisis in Russia
although you guys are buddy Buddies
Putin has been going off the rails
lately with the invasion and all there
are also rumors he's sick and not
healthy the US also really wants to take
him out which could mean regime change
may be on the horizon so you can keep
getting oil from Russia but it's best
not to be too dependent on loan add that
to the fact that most of your imported
oil has to be shipped through channels
controlled by the US Navy and you're
pretty much left out of America's Mercy
when it comes to your oil supply so
you're not in a very advantageous
position right now so if you're gonna
make sure China never runs out of oil or
electricity again if you're gonna make
sure the lights always stay on in your
Empire you're gonna have to diversify
your oil supply and the best way to do
that is to find an oil-rich country that
is not too friendly with America that
you can manipulate into doing exactly
what you want enter Iraq
foreign
[Music]
has been ravaged by violence and War
First America invaded in 2003 which led
to use of finding bombings deaf and ruin
then came the extremists and their
particular brain of Destruction but
beneath the rebel and ruined cities lies
some of the biggest oil reserves in the
world by some estimates Iraq hosts 12 of
all the world's known oil reserves if
that oil could be translated into money
in the bank Iraq will be one of the
wealthiest countries in the Middle East
if not the entire world so no wonder
America was so obsessed over Iraq
unfortunately for Iraq oil in the ground
doesn't easily translate into money in
the bank and after years of fighting
Wars and terrorism Iraq's government
doesn't exactly have the billions needed
to extract and refine their oil it needs
some outside help some outside funding
and for years America was the one that
offered them that helped see while
America invaded Iraq they got to pick
and choose the companies to mine and
refine the country's oil but then in
2020 Iraq's Parliament formally voted to
expel American troops from the country
apparently millions of deaths war crimes
and lies I finally made the Iraqi people
mad enough to kick the Americans outs
that along with President Joe Biden
announcing American troops would be
withdrawn from Iraq in 2021 meant the
country was left with a power and money
vacuum 20 years of war can be pretty
destructive and expensive and the Iraqi
government says it needs around 88
billion dollars to start rebuilding the
country the problem is there aren't many
countries out there with that kind of
money to lend to Iraq especially when
America isn't an option anymore but
luckily Iraq's situation presents you as
China with the perfect opportunity you
need reliable source of oil and Iraq has
more than enough oil to go around Iraq
needs money to rebuild its cities and
you'd be happy to hand over as many
billions as they need in exchange for
maybe some oil and Iraq's eyes you're
the perfect partner you're offering the
money with very few strings attached and
you don't have any history or bad blood
with the government you're offering Iraq
a clean slate and they're offering you
their oil so in 2019
announces the oil for construction
program as part of the program you
promise Iraq 10.5 billion dollars to
build 8 000 schools an airport and a
brand new modern Iraqi City and in
exchange all Iraq has to do is give you
oil but here's where things get even
sweeter because Iraq can't build all
those oral refineries and infrastructure
on its own you get to offer them some
help out of the goodness of your heart
of course so Chinese companies are
building Iraq's oil refineries they're
building their schools Road cities
airports it all sounds so Noble right
China is helping Iraq get back on its
feet after the evil Americans left them
in the dust but that's until you follow
the money see China isn't just giving
Iraq money no China is giving Iraq a
loan a 10 billion dollar loan to start
rebuilding the country War does that 10
billion dollar loan go Iraq guess that
money and then since that 10 billion
dollars right back to Chinese companies
to build that infrastructure so the
money started with the Chinese
government then it went to Iraq then it
quickly went back into the pocket of
Chinese companies ultimately controlled
by the Chinese governments and what is
Iraq left with 10 billion dollars in
debts that they had to pay back with
interest but that's not all Iraq then
has to sell China oil and then Iraq has
to use the money and made from that sale
to pay back its loan to China oh and the
guys Mining and refining the oil there
are also Chinese so when you look at it
this way you gotta admit that's pretty
genius now that's what we called the art
of the deal the art of the deal and
here's the kicker even if Iraq actually
manages to pay back all that money it's
gonna spend at least the next decade in
your debts and hence poor countries are
never able to pay back this kind of
debts that's why practically every poor
country is at risk of a debt crisis
right now and during this time while
Iraq is in debts you can fill up Iraq's
business sector and oil industry with
all your top contractors mines and firms
so even if that loan is eventually paid
off you would have infiltrated Iraq's
economy so well that they wouldn't be
able to survive without your companies
the country would be completely reliant
on your loan in your infrastructure to
keep things running and in return you'll
have an almost endless supply of oil
that America can't touch America spent
over two trillion dollars trying to
colonize Iraq but China all China had to
do was get Iraq to sign the dotted line
what China is doing to Iraq right now
has been what America has been doing to
the rest of the world for decades now
see contrary to popular belief war is
usually the last resort for America
their first choice is the shackle
countries in debt to make them their
slaves and they've done a very good job
at it take a look around you America and
the West have all the wealth and power
and yet they produce nothing America and
Europe don't produce anything no Asia
Africa and South America do all the hard
labor for them why because Asia Africa
and South America have become America
slaves but not slaves Bound by whips and
chains but through a new form of slavery
Financial slavery
see after researching all the videos for
this channel over the past few years I
started to notice the startling pattern
of financial slavery and the more I
looked into it the more I realized that
the most powerful corporations and
governments around the world are
literally only successful because of
this slavery just look at Apple Apple
would not make any money they would be
unprofitable if they didn't have a de
facto slave labor force in China making
their iPhones for them would suicide
ethanol this is the fundamental secret
that the most powerful institutions
around the world use to become
successful and it used to be that
Financial slavery was only reserved for
these powerful governments and
multinational corporations but the great
thing is thanks to modern technology you
too can now take advantage of the same
exact secret to become rich and Powerful
as well without being as evil as lung
and I expose all of this in my new
masterclass called Financial slavery
master class one t plus lessons all
narrated by me in the same addictive
documentary style you've come to love
You're Gonna Learn how the world is the
way it is how we got here and most
importantly how to take Advan advantage
of the same secret to gain more wealth
and power for herself there has never
been a course made like this I've spent
the last six months perfecting this and
you are gonna love it it's perhaps my
greatest body of work yet and on top of
that I wanted this masterclass to be a
chance for you to financially benefit
right away too so on top of the
life-changing stuff You're Gonna Learn
by enrolling you'll also be able to earn
around a hundred dollars for every
person you refer to the masterplus this
is just like Andrew takes legendary
affiliate program where we have
step-by-step lessons and resources on
how you can promote this Master Class by
posting Tick Tock clips of my videos but
instead of just getting 25 percent of
like Tate's program you're gonna get
four times that at around a hundred
dollars so scroll down and click the
link below to watch the first lesson of
this masterclass for free you will not
regret it scroll down click the link
below and buy now
foreign this is honestly a pretty genius
move on China's part so I respect their
ability to scheme but yeah I hope you
guys enjoyed the video and if you're new
here this is the channel you go to to
learn everything that they wouldn't
teach you in school we make
documentaries just like this one every
single week for free on money power war
and crime just like this one so if you
enjoyed this video click that subscribe
button below you can also follow me on
Instagram jaketran but that's going to
wrap it up thanks for being part of the
Washington Club stay dangerous out there
and I will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
foreign